okay one other headline here it's
something else from last week that I
wanted to cover and well I wasn't here
so I couldn't
um mention it now though Fox news
headline Buffalo police arrested 10 for
looting amid the deadly winter storm
officials in Buffalo New York said
Wednesday so it's last Wednesday night
the 10 arrests have been made in
response to looting following a deadly
winter storm that ravaged the region
over the Christmas weekend the Buffalo
Police Department said the arrests were
conducted by its newly created
anti-eluding task force the group was
formed after reports of break-ins to
businesses as the storm halted daily
life in the city
um on Tuesday Buffalo Police
Commissioner Joseph gramoglia warned
that looting would not be tolerated this
isn't people stealing food and medicine
and diapers who said they're destroying
stores they're stealing television
couches whatever else they can get their
hands on they're opportunists he said at
a press conference
so
um
that was for the major winter storm last
week and uh and we had you know we got
down to negative temperatures here in
Nashville negative two degrees other
places the the weather was even worse
and this led to looting but don't worry
because what we learned from some
leftists on Tick Tock is that uh the
looters had every right to do what they
did they'd have a right to exploit and
take advantage uh of this situation as
they so often do and um here's one tick
tocker explaining why
so I live in Buffalo this is a 33. this
is my car that's been buried in all of
this snow since last week and this is
outside my Granny's house a tree that's
been there since my aunt was a child
safe to say that it's a
[ __ ] out there right here go y'all
goblins who don't even live in the city
which by the way the Q-tip people are
the last ones to ever talk about
somebody stealing anything y'all
wouldn't be in this country had it not
been for y'all stealing it well y'all
are more focused on people looting and
trying to get necessities and things
that they need and yes a TV is a
necessity thing then the people who are
literally freezing to death in their own
home freezing to death outside because
this city did not shut down the way it
should have Byron Brown want to get on
here and talk about we told y'all we
knew this was gonna happen but why
didn't you close businesses when you
should have why you got everybody
rushing home at noon when the
you know storm is starting and now
people are literally dying in their cars
because they can't see and yeah it was
that bad I went out like at eight
o'clock in the morning before it started
and by the time I got out of Wegmans
right it was like maybe 9 30 10 o'clock
and it was bad and that was just the
beginning of the storm so if you don't
live in Buffalo even if you do live in
Buffalo you feel like you're better than
because people are out here stealing and
you would never first of all if you are
a Mayo monster that is how your
ancestors got everything from stealing
people are out here trying to get toilet
paper people are out here trying to get
you know just small little food from
Family Dollar and y'all
capitalism still everything that you
need babe because at the end of the day
this city continuously fails us whenever
we have any type of emergency Byron do
better
okay
male monster she calls white people
which I take exception to for a number
of reasons not the least of which is
that I um I I hate Mayo I was just
calling for the execution of people that
enjoy Mayo the other day so uh this is
no different from what we hear from the
left all the time infamously AOC you
know of course said that looters are
just out stealing bread to feed their
families
and yet
after the looters as we heard from the
police chief you know after the Reuters
looters run through a Walmart or Dollar
General or whatever it is that they're
stealing from the bread aisle is always
conspicuously left untouched not only
are they not stealing bread but it's
like the one thing they won't steal the
one thing that they won't steal are the
Necessities that that does those are all
of the the sections of the store that
are left untouched
um and that's because these are not
starving people who are out desperately
scrounging for resources
that's not what this is
these are vultures scavengers
victimizing their own Community
exploiting a crisis to steal from their
own Neighbors
the businesses that provide Necessities
to their own communities there they are
exploiting and victimizing
and this is also something to keep in
mind you know when you hear about
so-called food deserts
okay what is a what is a food desert
what do you think food desert would be
like an actual desert is a food desert
it's one of the things that defines a
deserts they're not a lot of they're not
a lot of resources of that kind
that's not what what it means when we
hear about food deserts this is an
effort
on the left they've come up with this
terminology
and it's an effort to
support the claim that there is still
this systemic racism against black
people in the United States
and um they have to get increasingly
desperate when they're when they're
trying to you know find and locate this
mythical Phantom systemic racism and so
they end up talking about things like
food deserts and so food desert is is
you know places especially in inner city
often in Black communities where there
are not uh there are not as many stores
and restaurants and grocery stores and
that sort of thing as there are other
parts of the city
that's a food desert
although like even if there were none at
all if you're living in a city you're
you're never going to be more than like
a five minute Uber ride away from some
kind of store
but if there are these food deserts if
there are
you know grocery stores and restaurants
that are shutting down shop in these
communities or refusing to open up in
the first place
maybe this is part of the reason why
I mean when you Prey Upon the businesses
in your community
and you Loot and Rob them then they're
going to go away and and then other
potential business owners are going to
look and they just if you've got someone
who wants to open up
their own restaurant their own grocery
store and they're trying they're
thinking of where should I put it
they're going to tend to put it in safer
places
where they're less likely to be
victimized in this way
seems rather obvious I realize but you
know still needs to be pointed out
against
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block and you can become a member and
use code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you over there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]